I can't wear these pretty colors anymore
your superhero suit caused a lot of
controversy Captain Marvel when people
saw your crease suit in the trailers
they freaked out but even though you
changed to something more like the one
from the comic books some people still
weren't happy there was so much thought
and care put into your costume design
and now it's one of the most iconic
costumes in the entire MCU designing
superhero suits takes a team of fashion
heroes and unfortunately not everyone
has an Edna mode on their side
tons of actors have complained about
their superhero costumes but that's not
the only reason they were given upgraded
versions keep watching to find out the
real reason why Marvel had to improve
their superhero costumes Andy Park is a
genius he's the director of visual
development for Marvel Studios which
means he is heavily involved in costume
design Andy has worked on a bunch of the
Marvel women's costumes including Black
Widow Scarlet Witch and mantis but he
really took it to the next level with
Captain Marvel she is a warrior so he
wanted her costume to look like a
soldier's outfit it needed to be
functional and practical
she doesn't wear heels like a lot of
female superheroes she wears space-age
combat boots her suit is designed to
protect her from battle as a Cree
warrior plenty of fans were upset when
Captain Marvel wasn't given a sash in
some of the comics she wears a red sash
around her waist
it looks cool in the comics but Andy
points out that it's just not practical
in real life if she's fighting bad guys
and flying around as sash is just gonna
get in the way it was so cool when
vision got a physical form Paul Bettany
did an amazing job bringing this evolved
AI to life Paul knows it's the role of a
lifetime but he has said the costume was
pretty miserable
it took him four hours to get into
costume and makeup every day you think
I'm a child of Ultron you're not they
didn't just paint his head red he
basically had pieces of rubber glued to
his skin rubber is an insulator so
things got really hot plus vision wears
a skin-tight costume that doesn't
breathe well it's uncomfortable and it's
hard to stay cool the costume designers
added tubes inside the suit that could
pump ice water it helped to cool him off
some but it was still pretty miserable
he was advised to meditate or read when
he's not filming to distract himself
Paul said he would think about how lucky
he was and how many people would give
anything to have the role it definitely
helped him keep going not everyone got
the ice tube option though some costumes
were just too tight but we need to go
[Music]
danos isn't just a terrible villain he's
pretty much the worst dad ever he
adopted nebula and Gamora and turned
them against each other to let me live
and he literally tormented nebula by
replacing her body parts with one by one
that made nebulas costume extremely
challenging for makeup and costume
designers it took hours for Karen
Gilliam to get into her costume every
day and nebula has no hair for her first
contract Karen was required to shave her
head but Karen was known for her
beautiful red hair she revealed at
comic-con one year that she had gone
bald by taking off her wig Karen didn't
want to stay bald though and Marvel had
to have her back in her second contract
she made sure that shaving her head
wasn't required
this made the visual Department get
creative they did figure out a way to
make nebula look like nebula without
care and going bald Marvel fans know
that the red skull is one of the evilest
villains in the franchise we first meet
him in Captain America the First Avenger
he is a Nazi scientist whose own
experiment went awry he escapes into
space but we find out in the Avengers
infinity war that he got his due he
spends his days alone guarding the soul
stone as penance Hugo Weaving played Red
Skull in Captain America he and Marvel
Studios didn't get along but they asked
him to reprise his role he turned it
down because he hated his costume it
took hours of makeup every day he found
it tedious and boring so Marvel was
forced to recast the role if Red Skull
looks different to you that's because he
was played by Ross Marquand from The
Walking Dead the costume and makeup
teams had to adjust to make him look as
similar to Hugo's red skull as possible
so holds a special place among the
Infinity stones superhero costumes are
definitely not comfortable they're bulky
plus the actors wearing them often film
in hot weather while performing
physically straining stunts
Thor's costume is no exception it was
easy to get overheated as the Norse god
so costume designers got creative Thor
wears a breastplate with his costume the
costume team figured out how to attach a
small air-conditioner underneath it it
would blow cool air under his costume
which help prevent Chris Hemsworth from
overheating he said it helped a lot but
that wasn't an option for everyone's
costumes some are just too tight to put
a fan in like Black Panther and Black
Widow Black Widow suit was too tight to
even wear underwear
she got heat sick several times and she
even hallucinate 'add she dehydrated
quickly from sweating and would have to
wring the sweat out of her socks every
night yeah we think we'd much rather
play Thor apparently being a god get you
an AC unit it's not like the costume
team tries to torment the actors they
really do try to make the costumes as
practical as possible most people think
that the costumes are all spandex or
leather but costume designer Judi Anna
makovski said that's not the case they
are usually using a type of stretch
cotton it's more breathable but they can
also diet print on it and add texture to
it but using the stretch cotton comes
with another challenge wrinkles both the
Judy Anna and Andy Park have said that
costumes might look good when the actor
is standing but when they move or film
stunts they wrinkle like crazy they have
to add materials to stop that from
happening
plus most of them have multiple suits
made of different materials armor is
harder and often 3d printed there are
costumes that are fresh for battle and
others that are scuffed to show after
the fights they even have to adjust the
costumes for when the actors need to be
on a harness to fly who knew so much
went into these costumes keep watching
to find out all the changes that happen
to turn Captain Marvel from a Kree
fighter to an Avenger
where's fury of all the MCU costumes the
Iron Man suit might have undergone the
most change sure they look similar but
you'll be surprised to find out how
different they really are in the early
movies Robert Downey jr. really did wear
a huge bulky suit as Iron Man Robert has
said she is not claustrophobic but that
suit
nearly broke him he said he nearly had a
personality meltdown after a few hours
in the suit it was almost too much to
bear Don Cheadle who plays war machine
has said pretty much the same thing
about his suit he compared it to
something used in the Spanish
Inquisition
when Gweneth Paltrow suited up she made
a comment saying that women must be
tougher it was uncomfortable but it was
just a costume she said but hey no two
costumes are built the same these days
Iron Man's suit is entirely CGI Robert
wears a partial helmet and something
that looks like a harness then he wears
body capture technology and the suit is
added later we bet Thor vision Black
Widow and black panther are pretty
jealous of his new costume you throw
another moon at me Tom Holland has done
an amazing job at bringing spider-man to
life but playing the teenage hero isn't
easy tom has talked a lot about how
tough wearing the spider suit is he
can't wear anything underneath it and he
has to completely strip down to go to
the bathroom he also wears a helmet
under the mast to give his head the
right shape that impedes his vision
which resulted in him getting punched in
the nose it's also really hot to wear
when you're doing a bunch of stunts Tom
really struggled with staying hydrated
at first it was hard to take off the
whole mask and helmet to take drinks so
the costume designers came up with an
ingenious solution they made the eyes on
the helmet pop out then someone is able
to stick a straw through one of the eye
holes down to his mouth it might not be
glamorous but it gets the job done
[Music]
there's no doubt about it
the cast of Marvel movies are some of
the most buff stars in Hollywood they
have to train hard to get those muscles
so that they look the part of a
superhero so imagine how disappointing
it must be to put on a superhero costume
and have all those muscles disappear
according to Judy on omakase the fabric
that they use for most the costumes can
make muscles vanish it flattens
everything out so you can't see all the
toned muscles that just wouldn't do so
she and the other costume designers had
to come up with a solution they mold and
sculpt fake muscles to put on the actors
inside their costumes
this makes the actors look a lot more
buff than they actually are smash when
you think of Captain Marvel you probably
just pictured the blue red and gold suit
but so much went into turning Carol
Danvers from a Kree soldier into a
proper hero red blue and yellow are
primary colors and she's now the primary
hero of the Avengers hey Peter burger
but her black and green Kree suit didn't
just change colors there are triangles
all over Captain Marvel suit triangles
are the strongest and most balanced
shape which describes her character
perfectly the stripes on her shoulders
symbolizing military ranks she kept the
star on her chest but she added two wide
stripes it symbolizes that she promoted
herself to a guardian of Earth as well
as the protector of the scrolls we just
love how much detail and symbolism went
into her costume she definitely has the
most impressive on-screen costume change
which Marvel hero do you think has the
best costume let us know in the comment
section thanks for watching subscribe to
the things for more great videos and hit
that like button on your way out
see you next time
[Music]